HERE'S PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION.
HE'S A MUSICAL >> THE
CONVERSATION ON THE LEFT
REVOLVES ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY
AROUND IDENTITY, WHICH IS ABOUT
ME.
NARCISSISM.
IT'S ABOUT ME.
BUT YOU KEPT TALKING ABOUT
ECONOMICS.
THAT USED TO BE THE CENTRAL
CONVERSATION ON THE LEFT, OR IN
AMERICA ACTUALLY.
>> YEAH.
>> WHY NO MORE?
>> THE ESTABLISHMENT HAS LEARNED
HOW TO CO-OPT IDENTITY POLITICS
TO PUT THE BRAKES ON ECONOMICS
INJUSTICES.
THE JOKE I DO, IF YOU WANT TO
HELP, I SAY IF YOU WANT TO HELP
BLACK PEOPLE, NOTHING WOULD HELP
THEM MORE THAN FREE COLLEGE,
STUDENT LOAN RELIEF, AND
MEDICARE FOR ALL AND A LIVING
WAGE.
YOU WANT TO HELP THEM?
THAT WILL BE THE WAY TO HELP
HIM.
BUT JOE BIDEN COMES IN AND DOES
NONE OF THOSE THINGS.
YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT QUESTION MUST BE ONE OH, I
DO UNDERSTAND.
>> THEY ARE ALL SIGNALS.
WE ARE SIGNALING THAT WE WANT TO
HELP THE MINORITY COMMUNITY BUT
WE ARE NOT ACTUALLY HELPING
THEM.
SO THAT IS WHAT IDENTITY
POLITICS IS.
IT'S A BIG DIVERSION.
THE JOKE I SAY IF IT WAS 1860,
THE DEMOCRATS WILL BE BRAGGING
ABOUT THEIR FIRST TRANSGENDERED
SLAVE OWNER.
WHEN I'M TRYING TO TELL PEOPLE
IS WHEN YOU VOTE FOR THEM, WHEN
YOU VOTE FOR SOMEBODY INSIDE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY NO MATTER WHAT
THEY SAY, NO MATTER WHAT THEY
BELIEVE, THEY ARE WANT TO GO
ALONG WITH NANCY PELOSI AND
NANCY PELOSI GOES ALONG WITH
GOLDMAN SACHS.
WHEN YOU ARE VOTING FOR SOMEONE
INSIDE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, YOU
ARE VOTING FOR GOLDMAN SACHS.
THEY ARE NOT STANDING UP TO
THOSE PEOPLE.
THE IDEA THAT WE HAVE
PROGRESSIVES INSIDE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS ACTUALLY
MORE THAN THE PROGRESSIVE
MOVEMENT TO HAVE HIM THERE.
IT GIVES THEM THE THOUGHTS AND
IMPRESSION THAT THERE IS
SOMEBODY IN GOVERNMENT FIGHTING
FOR YOU, THAT THERE IS ONE PARTY
THAT IS KIND OF ON YOUR SIDE.
THE QUICKER PEOPLE REALIZE THAT
IT AREN'T ON YOUR SIDE, THAT
BOTH PARTIES ARE NOT ON YOUR
SIDE, THEY ONLY SERVE THE
OLIGARCHY, THEY ARE BACK IN THE
OLIGARCHY.
IT WAS STOLEN WAY BEFORE TRUMP.
UNTIL THAT HAPPENS, WE WON'T
EVER HAVE REAL CHANGE.
>> Tucker: WHAT ABOUT ACROSS
THE AIRPORT HAS?
SHE'S ON INSTAGRAM.
>> SHE CAMPAIGNED ON A VOTE OF
MEDICARE FOR ALL.
SHE CAMPAIGNED ON CREATING WHAT
SHE CALLED A RUCKUS, MEANING YOU
HAVE TO STOP BEING POLITE.
THIS IS A QUOTE.
YOU HAVE TO STOP BEING POLITE.
WE TRIED BEING POLITE AND IT GOT
US NOWHERE.
IT WASN'T UNTIL WE STARTED
ACTING OUT AND SPEAKING
IMPOLITELY THAT WE EVEN CREATED
THE CIRCUMSTANCES FOR CHANGE.
THAT'S WHAT SHE TWEETED.
SO I'M JUST DOING WHAT SHE SAID.
SO I STARTED TO PUT HEAT ON
PEOPLE LIKE AOC AND ALL OF THESE
JUSTICE DEMOCRATS AND THE SQUAD
TO FORCE THE VOTE.
THEY SET I WAS COMMITTING
VIOLENCE AGAINST THEM WITH MY
WORDS.
THAT'S HOW SCARED THEY ARE.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
WERE YOU?
>> THAT'S VIOLENT?
THAT IS HOW AFRAID THEY WERE.
THEY HAD PEOPLE WRITE HIT PIECES
ON ME IN THE DAILY, NEW YORK
MAGAZINE, "NEWSWEEK," BUGS FADE.
THEY TRIED TO SHUT ME DOWN AND
SQUELCH ME.
THEY MADE ME TREND ON TWITTER OR
NEGATIVELY.
COULDN'T SHUT ME UP AND THEY
COULDN'T STOP ME.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH
ME, BECAUSE AGAIN, THEY HAD
WIKIPEDIA PUTTING SMEARS ON ME
THAT I CAN'T GET RID OF, CNN IS
CALLING ME NAMES.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE WHAT IS GOING
ON.
I AM JUST A COMEDIAN, A POTHEAD
COMEDIAN IN HIS GARAGE.
WHAT YOU CAN DO WHEN YOU WANT TO
TELL THE TRUTH.
YOU CAN CREATE A RUCKUS AND I
DID.
SO NOT EVERYBODY SEES THAT THOSE
PEOPLE ARE FAKERS AND THEY ARE
CORRUPT.
THE REASON I SAY THEY ARE
CORRUPT, IT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY
TAKE CORPORATE MONEY AND DO THE
BEATINGS OF CORPORATIONS, BUT
THEY ARE DOING THE BIDDING OF
THEIR OWN CAREER, THEIR OWN SOFT
FEELINGS.
IF I GO ALONG WITH THE
ESTABLISHMENT, I'M GOING TO GET
A BOOK DEAL.
I'M GOING TO GET SPEAKING FEES
AND BE IN CONGRESS FOR AT LEAST
FIVE YEARS.
AND THEN I GET A PENSION FOR THE
REST OF MY LIFE.
THAT'S CORRUPT AND THAT IS WHY
THEY ARE NOT PUSHING BACK.
NANCY PELOSI CAN CRUSH YOU.
WE WILL FUND SOMEBODY IN A
PRIMARY TO YOUR LEFT JUST LIKE
SHE DID TO AOC, RIGHT?
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE ALL AFRAID
OF.